talk by Andrea Khalid Angelou and you
tell us about soft testing as an
approach to 35 cool so yeah thank you so
in this talk I would like to tell you
about self testing as an approach to
certifying quantum systems so I think
that if you're familiar with self
testing already there wouldn't be so
much new in this thought but if you're
not and hopefully you learn something
new so let me start by motivating first
why we should care about oops let's see
about certifying quantum devices so one
first reason is that we might like to
validate experimental advances from say
Google or IBM and you might argue that
it's reasonable to trust at Google say
it's not fabricating their data but it's
still possible that their quantum
computer is faulty in a way that we're
just not detecting and perhaps a second
more important reason is that in
cryptographic in a cryptographic setting
devices quantum devices can not only be
faulty but they could be programmed
outright maliciously or adversarially so
we need certification procedures in
order to protect the honest parties and
there is actually more in fact the
question of certifying quantum devices
in recent years has found some very nice
connections to the foundations of
quantum information so questions about
entanglement and quantum correlation
sets and also connections to complexity
theory so I'll briefly touch upon the
former towards the end of the talk and
you'll hear about the latter from an and
later and tomorrow in this series of
talks about miv star okay so how can a
classical user even hope to certify any
quantum device well this question has
been studied primarily in two settings
the first setting is where we assume
that the quantum device that we want to
test consists of two non communicating
components or servers and this is a
natural assumption in some settings and
less than others for instance if you are
thinking about kid
distribution then the two parties Alice
and Bob are already naturally separated
and they each hold on to one of the
components of the device in this setting
we typically are able to obtain
statements that have information
theoretic security the other setting in
which this question has been studied is
certainly more practical it is the
single server model in which we don't
have to worry about ensuring that the
two components don't communicate and
here typically however we only get
security statements under computational
assumptions so in this talk I will be
working in the first setting and here is
a plan for this talk so introduce the
model and the assumptions and I'll give
you a definition of self testing this
will be the first part of the talk in
the second part I will cover some basic
results and techniques in self testing
in particular I will revisit some games
that you'll probably have already seen
like the CSH game and a Magic Square
game but I'll dive a little bit more
deeply into these and in the final part
I will sort of lightly survey some more
recent results the state of the art and
I'll also mention some applications to
the little corn computation and also
these connections with questions about
entanglement okay so a partial answer to
the question of 35 quantum device is
provided by Bell's Theorem Bell's
Theorem is a landmark result in physics
it was discovered in the 1960s now
describe it to you as it also gives me
the opportunity to describe the setting
that we are working in so consider two
two parties Alice and Bob and they're on
distant planets there so far they can
communicate imagine that each of them
has a particle and say that they decide
to probe their particle with a question
so they can think of this as a
measurement setting either position they
can measure position or momentum and
they note this choice by a bit X for
Alice and Y for Bob and upon probing
their particle they each get an answer
or measurement outcome
call it a for Alice and B for Bob and
certainly one can consider the joint
probability distribution of their
outcomes their answers am be given a
particular choice of measure and setting
say x and y above zero they both decide
to measure position and there are then
obviously three other probability
distributions for all the other possible
choices or measurement settings and in
some sense these distributions capture
all of the statistics of this particular
experiment so I'll refer to this data as
a correlation now classically in
Newtonian physics a correlation is
explained in what is known as a hidden
variable model where we assume that
there is a an underlying variable lambda
that specifies the global state of the
universe in particular once you fix
lambda and a question X for Alice the
answer a that she sees is just a fixed
deterministic function of X and lambda
likewise when you fix lambda and a
question Y for Bob the answer B that Bob
sees is just a fixed function of Y and
lambda now there could be some
randomness in lambda but essentially
this is how the correlation is explained
and the content of guelph theorem is
that there exist some quantum
correlations we just cannot be explained
in a local hidden variable model and
this in particular can happen when the
two particles are entangled
now Bell's Theorem has a lot of
implications and some are philosophical
but it also has a strong operational
significance in particular it gives us a
test to detect the presence of
entanglement or genuine quantumness in
the following sense
imagine a verifier who has a quantum
device and assume that this device
consists of two non communicating
components now we typically personify
these components we call them Alice and
Bob these components don't have to be on
distant planets they could be in the
same lab so long as the verifier is
ensuring that they're not communicating
and one way that you could do this is by
executing whatever tests
is doing quickly enough the not even
light could travel from one component to
the other and so as part of this test
show sample some questions X&Y probe the
two components get answers a and B these
are classical questions so repeat this
experiment a bunch of times and this
will allow her to estimate the
probability that a B ok probability of a
B given X Y for all possible values of a
b x and y assume that they're taken from
some finite sets and then what you can
do is she can just check whether the
correlation can or cannot be explained
by a local hidden variable model and
this is a check that you can do
efficiently by the way and if it cannot
then shall be quite confident that
indeed there was entanglement present
between the two components of her device
of course all of this is assuming that
quantum mechanics is correct ok so let
me give give you a concrete example of
our witness to Bell's Theorem it's the
CH SH game which I'm sure most of you
who are listening will have seen already
so it's called the game because you can
think of Alice and Bob as playing
cooperatively in a game refereed by the
verifier the game consists of a one
round interaction between the verifier
and the two players of provers and
there's a deterministic function which
says whether Alice and Bob win the game
or they lose in the case of the CSH game
the questions and answers are all a
single bit and the condition is that
alice and bob win if the parity of their
answer bits is equal to the product of
the question bits and it's well known
that for classical players if the
questions are sample uniformly around
them by the verifier classical players
can win at mostly probability
probability 3/4 but it turns out that if
you allow alice and bob to share
entanglement then they can go beyond
this they can win with up to probability
cos squared pi over 8 which is about 85%
and they can do this by sharing what is
known as an EPR pair it's a maximally
entangled pair of qubits
and so to tie things back to Bell's
Theorem right observing a winning
probability greater than 3/4 essentially
certifies the presence of January in
quantumness okay but there is more and
this is particularly important for
certification in fact if Alice and Bob
win the game the CSH game with
probability that is optimal then it
turns out that they must be sharing any
PR pair this is the unique state that
allows them to win optimally and there
are specific measurements that they
should perform on each of their qubits
and so what we've learned is that there
exists correlations like the one that
wins the CSH game optimally which are
compatible with a unique one strategy so
a verifier that observes an optimal
winning probability is able to
characterize for device entirely and we
refer to this phenomenon as self testing
so informally right self testing is a
certification of quantum states and
measurements based only on the observed
correlations and I would like to
emphasize that this is a uniquely
quantum phenomenon there's nothing quite
like this classically because you're
able to essentially characterize the
system and the operation of two
computationally unbounded provers
completely information theoretic
statement the only thing that is being
assumed is that quantum mechanics is
correct are there any questions so far
that I can answer Alex we're good right
I'm just checking good yeah if there are
some if there's any questions I would
let you know ok thanks cool ok so the
theory of self testing has developed
significantly in recent years it has
found concrete applications in quantum
cryptography to the delegation of
quantum computation key distribution
randomness expansion and recently it has
also found applications in
characterizing the complexity of the
class MA P star of multiple interactive
proofs
we're entangled provers which you'll
hear about from anon also tomorrow and
it has also recently found some very
nice connections with foundational
questions about
tangle man and quantum correlation sets
and this I'll briefly touch upon at the
end of the talk okay so in the next part
of the talk I will describe to you some
basic results and techniques in
particular the plan is I will tell you
I'll give you a sketch of the proof to
see to save yourself tests an EPR pair
and then I'll describe another popular
game which is called a Magic Square game
I'm sure many of you will have also seen
this but I'll go a little bit more in
detail in this and this will allow me to
describe a presentation theoretic
approach to self testing before I do
this let me just formalize some of the
notions that I already talked about so
that I can make my statements a bit more
precise so I mentioned correlations at
the start
the setting is again to non
communicating provers players and a
verifier they're having one round of
communication now formally a correlation
is specified by some finite sets capital
X Y MB you can think of x and y as
question sets and a BS answer set from
which all of the lowercase letters are
taken and as I was saying earlier a
correlation captures the statistics of a
particular experiment so correlation is
formally an example of distributions and
there is one distribution for each
possible pair of question that Alice and
Bob can get and these are distributions
over the answer the nd I will say that
the correlation is classical if it can
be realized in a local hidden variable
model okay so what about a quantum
correlation well a con correlation is
one that can be realized or generated by
a quantum strategy and what I mean by
this is the following so a quantum
strategy is specified by a state sigh
which could be in tango is a state
shared by Alice and Bob so you can think
of H a is being Alice's Hilbert space
and HB as being Bob's moreover it is
specified by a set of measurement or
observables ax on Alice's side there's
one for each possible question that she
get and a set of measurements B Y
likewise for Bob observables B Y and you
can think of their strategy as being you
know before the game begins they meet
and they shared a stepside after that
they're separated they can communicate
when Alice gets questioned X she will
measure the observable a X and return as
an answer the outcome of this
measurement and the same would do Bob
and this captures the most general
strategy of to quantum players and of
course if this is what they do then it's
easy to see that the probability of
seeing answers a and B given questions x
and y is simply given by the appropriate
so the overlap of the appropriate
projectors onto the steps i we're here
ax with this superscript little a just a
projector onto the answer a
and okay let me just give you a bit more
formal definition of self-testing fix
some question-and-answer sets XY a and B
we say that the correlation P star on
this question answer sets self tests a
certain quantum strategy if up to local
isometries this is the unique strategy
the retains P star now there is a degree
of freedom of local isometries or local
changes of basis because this are they
leave the correlation environment
they're just undetectable and the
probabilities but other than this we
would like that the strategy here is the
unique one that attains P star okay let
me let me just pause a moment five
seconds for questions okay so we want a
robust version of this statement right
so you know if you obtain the strategy
with P star minus epsilon then you know
the status slips long close to is a true
is that is that is that a requirement as
well yeah that is certainly something
that we desire I haven't included it in
the definition but yeah that is called
exactly robustness and most of the self
tests that people prove they do have
robustness property so I will yeah yes
exactly we'll discuss that later on
thanks thank you good so okay so let's
have a closer look at this HSH game so
many of you will have seen this also
recast as an inequality this HSH
inequality one can define the following
operator s which is called a bell
operator defined in terms of the
observables a0 and a1 on Alice's side
and b0 b1 on Bob's and this Bell
operator s captures the success
probability of Alice and Bob in the
sense that the expectation of s OMPs I
were precise the state shared by Alice
and Bob equals this expression four
times the probability that they win -
the probability that they lose so it
captures entirely their success
probability
game it turns out that classically this
expectation value when sighs a product
state is upper bounded by two and
quantumly when you're lopsided to be
entangled the upper bound is two square
root of two okay and this corresponds to
the COS square PI over eight that we saw
earlier and this upper bound is known as
zero Suns bound now its citizens bond
has a relatively straightforward proof
the most direct way that I know how to
show it is the following so you can
start by squaring the Bell operator s so
the coda calculation will be a bit
complicated but there will be many
constellations and what you obtain in
the end is that s squared equals four
times the identity minus this tensor
product of these two commutator 's a 0
and a 1 and B 0 and B 1 and you can
bound the norms of the two commutator 's
the infinity norm the two commutators by
two and so this allows you to give a
bound on the norm of s squared which is
eight so the largest eigenvalue is 8 and
by taking a square root one can deduce
that the largest eigen value of s has to
be to square root of two and this is
desired at the desired upper bound now
the nice observation about this proof is
that in order to saturate this
inequality to attain to square root of
two it must be that both the norm of the
commutator ZAR equal to two and with
little work one can show that this
implies that a zero and a one must anti
commute and likewise b0 and b1 must also
anti commute so with relatively little
work we were able to deduce a pretty
strong relation between the operators on
Alice's side and similarly on both side
and it is often the case in self testing
that thinking about it in terms of
testing relations between operators is a
very fruitful point of view on the way
to getting a complete characterization
of the state and the measurements and so
in the next one or two slides I'll show
you how we can
use this anti commutation relations to
actually pinpoint exactly the state that
achieves the maximal violation as an EPR
pair are there any let me just pause
five seconds for questions
okay so and this was the result I think
was proved by summers inverter but this
sketch proved that I'll show you is a
bit different so we can start with a
strategy sigh with observable ax and B Y
and suppose that it attains the maximum
violation to square root of 2 now in
general this need not be a cubed
strategy it could be very high
dimensional but let's assume just for a
moment that it is a cubed strategy well
then from the previous slide we know
that is 0 anyone anticommute same for b0
and b1 and now okay what I've sorry what
I mean by a cubed strategy is a side the
state of two qubits and ax and B why are
just single qubit observables so in
particular a 0 and a 1 are just 2 by 2
matrices the anti commute
they also Square to the identity because
the plus or minus 1 eigen values
essentially they are a 2 dimensional
representation of the polygroup and we
know that the polygroup has a unique two
dimensional irreducible two dimensional
representation and these are precisely
the Pauli matrices unique up to changes
of basis and so what we deduce is that
up to a change of basis is 0 anyone have
to be rather the generators of a poly
group so Sigma Z and Sigma X and we can
make the same deduction for b0 and b1 ok
so with this knowledge we can rewrite
the Bell operator s which was just an
operator on two qubits by substituting
explicitly what we derived so up to a
change of base is a local change of
basis the Bell operator s can be written
explicitly in this form and this is a
concrete 4x4 matrix so we can just
compute the largest the again vector
corresponding to the largest eigen value
and it turns out to be any PR pair ok so
this is how we show that the state that
achieve maximal violation if it's a
qubit strategy has to be an EPR pair
let me let me just pause again a moment
for questions
and yeah yeah or general
you know larger states you know how to
say anything about them oh yeah
absolutely in the next slide I will tell
you yeah so exactly so so what about a
non qubit strategy well there's a quite
handy two linear algebra that comes to
the rescue which is jordan's lemma which
allows us to reduce the analysis to the
cubit case
so essentially jordan's lemma says that
we can find a basis for alice's hilbert
space that makes a 0 and a 1
simultaneously block diagonal with two
by two blocks so to the blocks are two
by two matrices we can apply jordan's
lemma also on Bob side so find the basis
that makes b0 and b1 both block diagonal
with 2 by 2 blocks and crucially we can
only apply jordan's lemma because there
are only two observables per per Hilbert
space okay and so this is what I won't
sketch the details after this but this
is what allows you to reduce the
analysis to the qubit case so indeed HSH
softest an EPR pair and you can you
don't have to assume a dimension on the
starting strategy good so this is all
that I wanted to say about CH SH let me
move to another popular game which is
called the Magic Square game many of you
will also have heard about this but I'll
go a little bit more into the details so
in this game the verifier proceeds as
follows for Alice the verifier was
sampled uniformly at random a column of
this 3x3 square and she will ask Alice
to return the entries of this square 0 1
entries sorry the entries of this column
they should be 0 1 entries and the
constraint they should satisfy is that
the parity of the sum should be odd ok
for Bob she will sample uniformly at
random a row and ask Bob to return the
entries of this row in the constraint
that should satisfy is that the parity
of the sum should be even
Bob there is a third constraint which is
that on whichever cell the row and the
column intersect Alice and Bob should
give the same answer they should be
consistent
now if Alice and Bob's answers to
satisfy all of these two constraints
then together they win the game
otherwise they lose and if you stare for
long enough at this game you realize
that because Bob doesn't know what
question Alice is being asked and
vice-versa the best this consistency
condition enforces it the best that
classical players can do is simply to
agree before the game begins on a fixed
3x3 square on the nine entries of a
fixed 3x3 square and just answer by
using the enters of this square
and now if they if they do this if the
agreement Square and use the entries of
this square they'll always be consistent
so the question just becomes whether
there exists a 3x3 square that satisfies
all of the odd and even parity
constraints and unfortunately such a
square well fortune fortunately may be
such a square doesn't exist and it's
quite easy to see this it's because if
you sum the entries column by column you
deduce that the total party should be
odd plus odd odd which is all the
whereas if you sum them row by row you
would deduce that it should be even plus
even plus even which is even and this
gives you a contradiction
so whatever Square t by GA square Alice
and Bob agree upon they're always fail
in the game on at least one out of the
nine possible questions so the classical
optimal winning probability in this game
is 8 over 9 but surprisingly if Alice
and Bob are allowed to share
entanglement then they can win this game
actually with probability 1 and they can
do this by just sharing to appear pairs
this is sufficient okay but ok let's
take a closer look at this game so
essentially it is characterized by a
system of linear equations modulo 2 so
what we are requiring is that the
entries in each row sum to 0 modulo 2
the entries in each column should sum to
1 and for convenience let me just
rewrite this system by replacing
additions with products and the zeros
and ones with plus or minus 1 so this is
just the equivalent system and as we
argued earlier there is no plus or minus
1 assignment to the variables such that
all the equations are satisfied however
there exist what is referred to as an
operator solution an operator solution
is an assignment to the variables of the
variables two operators in fact two
observables so hermitian operators with
plus or minus 1 again values
such that all of the equations are
satisfied now of course these are
operator equations so we're replacing
plus one and minus one with identity and
minus the identity but the equations are
the same as before essentially and I
guess one thing that you might be
worried about is not because we're
dealing with operators in general it
matters the order in which we take the
products but to not worry about this we
will just require that the operators
appearing in the same equation should
commute and if all of these constraints
are satisfied we call this an operator
solution now why should we care about an
operator solution well because it
implies a perfect strategy in the game
and we can see this as follows so let X
1 2 X 9 be an operator solution to the
Magic Square game and suppose that these
are operators on a d-dimensional Hilbert
space let's say C to the D for
concreteness the strategy of allison bob
is the following they will start by
sharing a maximally entangled state a
pair of of maximally entangled qubits
where the local dimension is d where d
is the same as the dimension of the
space on which the operators act and
when Alice is being asked a column she
will measure the observables in that
column now because they commute there is
no problem she can measure them
simultaneously and this will give her
some plus or minus 1 measurement
outcomes and because the observables
multiply to minus d identity we are
guaranteed that the plus or minus
outcomes have a product of minus 1 so
Alice will satisfy parity constraint now
similarly when we ask Bob Dorough Bob
will measure the observables in that row
get plus or minus 1 outcomes and now we
are guaranteed that the product of these
outcomes is plus 1 so the parity
constraint of Bob is also fine what
about the consistency condition
well this follows because on the
intersecting cell Alice and Bob are
measuring the same
observable in particular they're doing
so on two halves of a maximally
entangled state and this means that
they're gonna get the same outcome so
this is a give them a perfect strategy
in the magic square game let me pause
for four questions here okay good
so you might be wondering right so an
operator solution implies a perfect
strategy yeah enjoy there's a question
yeah who the pension is is this operator
solution correspondence a general way to
find perfect solutions for games or does
it only work for the Magic Square game
specifically this this works in general
yeah this works in general for games
that are based on linear systems of
equations like the Magic Square game but
there are others too and in fact most of
the things that I'll say after this will
also follow for such games so these are
called linear constraint system games
good and so one thing that you might be
wondering is does the perfect us do all
perfect strategies in the game have this
form so the reverse implication okay do
they all consist of operator solutions
acting on an EPR pair and this was
answered affirmatively by Cleveland
stuff soft stirring in 2016 so indeed
the better solution and perfect
strategies are essentially equivalent so
when we think about self testing via the
Magic Square game what we care about is
the question is there a unique perfect
strategy for the Magic Square game and
because of this equivalence this becomes
the same as the question is there a
unique operator solution it turns out
that we can study this question
elegantly in representation theoretic
framework okay so this is what I'll show
you in the next one or two slides and if
you're not super familiar with
representation Theory hopefully at least
that the high-level picture will also be
be clear
so and this is something that appears in
the work of clearance lobster so one can
define a group in the algebraic sense
which abstracts the properties of an
operator solution so we call this a
solution group and the group is defined
by having these two following generators
so X 1 through X 9 these are abstract
elements right but you can think of them
as corresponding to the operators in
your operator solution there is also a
special generator J which you can think
of as being having the role of minus 1
or minus J identity and now the elements
of the group are all the possible
products of the generators so all of the
words that you can write by
concatenating X 1 2 X 9 and J and
subject to the following relations or
constraints so we require that for every
I X I squares to the identity element of
the group here is just the identity
element of the group and this captures
the fact that observables Square to the
identity we also require that J squares
to the identity moreover in keeping with
this analogy with the operator solution
we would like elements appearing in the
same equation to commute so exercise
that are in the same row and same column
commute and finally we want that all of
the equations should be satisfied in the
sense that elements in the same row
multiplied to the identity and elements
in the same column should multiply to j
j here is taking the role of minus 1
minus identity now this group the
solution group abstracts properties of
an operator solution and it does so in
the following precise sense in the sense
that representations of the solution
group that map j to minus the identity
are precisely the operator solutions so
representation is just a mapping of the
group elements to matrices which
preserves the structure of the group so
here all I'm saying is if you have a
representation in maps J 2 minus
identity
is an operator solution vice-versa so
the big takeaway from this slide is that
we can study the operator solutions of
the magic square game by studying the
representations of its solution group in
particular if there is a unique
representation with J which sends you to
my site and there's a unique operator
solution are there any questions about
this let me pause again for five seconds
so so why did the second bullet the fact
that why do you need appropriate
elements in the same equation commute to
race are important so that is important
because we want this group to abstract
the properties of an operator solution
and recorded an operator solution had
this property that elements appear in
the same row and same comment commute
the reason why it had this property is
that we wanted to when we construct the
perfect strategy from it we wanted to be
able to measure this observable
simultaneously that's why they had to
come okay okay so we want to study
operator solution by selling there a
presentation of of the solution group so
it turns out in the case of the Magic
Square game the solution group is
isomorphic to just two copies of the
polygroup and you one can show that
there's a unique reducible
representation that sends J unique up to
changes of basis unitary changes of
bases that map's j2 minus the identity
and this representation happens to be of
dimension 4 so what this tells us is
that up to local changes of bases there
is a unique perfect strategy for the
Magic Square game and it involves the
two players sharing a pair of maximally
entangled qubits where the local
dimension is 4 this is the same as to
appear pairs the same state and moreover
the operated observables that they use
are essentially isomorphic to two copies
of the polygroup so this is how we prove
the Magic Square game self test to EPR
pairs
and you can find the sort of more
details about this and how the same
ideas apply to other linear constraint
system games in a work of myself angelic
start but I should mention that the
question of whether I mean the proof
that the Magic Square game self test to
appear pairs is also found in a previous
work of wu at all in 2016 good so in the
final part of the talk let me I just
want to survey likely some more recent
results the state of the art and I want
to briefly mention some applications to
the delegation of quantum computations
and also some of these connections that
I promised with quantum correlation sets
and entanglement so before getting to
these applications let me just clarify
some questions that you might have in
your mind already so so far all of the
self testing statements that we have
seen are for maximally entangled states
you might be wondering whether it's
possible to self-test non maximally
entangled States sorry sorry
so a string is asking how is the shared
state derived from the operator solution
how do how do you prove that it's an
obeah this is the question how do you
prove that it's an EPR pair yeah that's
right
what's the correspondence between the
shared state and either the solution
group of the operator solution yeah so
the way that you prove that it has to be
a maximally entangled state so I sort of
list a little bit over this but so it's
kind of implicit in the work of
Cleveland's lobster but the way that you
prove it is by showing that essentially
it's a state that is stabilized by a
certain set of operators so X X and Z Z
for instance and that way you know that
it has to be an EPR pair instead that
we're in the case of qubits if it's
stabilized by X X and Z Z then has to be
an EPR prayer and from where did you get
these constraints yeah so these are from
the actually you get them from the con
the conditions the fact that when you
sort of when they're Alice and Bob are
both applying the same observables
so there's right then they should get
the same answer so essentially this
tells you that x5 acting on Alice's side
apply to psi is equal to X five applied
on pumps I on Bob side okay yeah that
makes sense
yes thanks good so all right you might
be wondering whether we can self not
maximally entangled states self-test the
answer is yes there is a generalization
of the CH SH inequality which is called
tilde CH SH this is the one parameter
family of Belle inequalities and it
allows to self test any entangled state
any partially entangled state of qubits
this inequality was proposed by a cinema
star and peroneal and it's been studied
in these two works now you might also be
wondering if it's possible to self test
higher dimensional states than just one
or two EPR pairs again the answer is
positive it turns out that in fact all
pure bipartite and tango states of any
finite local dimension can be self
tested meaning then you can write down
for any state that you want softest you
can write down a correlation that's out
as this state another natural question
that you might be wondering about is all
of these self tests they certify a very
specific state and and measurement can
we somehow bootstrap with this self test
to certify and set an arbitrary full
flash quantum computation and what I
would like is a verifiable delegated
quantum computation protocol and what I
mean by this is the following
so the verifier has some quantum circuit
in mind she would like to delegate it to
to potentially untrusted or not
communicating servers Allison Bob the
protocol should consist of an
interaction between the verifier and the
two servers at the end of which the
verifier either outputs reject or a bit
and the guarantee that we want is that
she either rejects
or if she outputs a bit this will be the
correct outcome of the computation with
high probability and if you think about
it it will be apparent that we need two
more ingredients to get something like
this
the first ingredient which is what we
know was hinting at earlier is any test
that we use should be robust right
because impact is the verifier can never
estimate a winning probability exactly
but only up to some statistical
confidence so we need whatever softest
we employ to hold also approximately
meaning that the close to optimal
winning permeability certifies a close
to ideal state and for the case of the
chssh game in fact we know that the it
robustly self tests one EPR pair this is
from independent works of make a young
and scrawny and Rijkaard in grandpa's
irani I believe and if you're interested
in the the best sort of analytical
robustness balance for the state usage
inequality I believe that these are
found in a work of cannae our scheme so
this is the first ingredient the second
one is that it's probably not enough to
test a single EPR pair we should test
more appear pairs or probably a higher
dimensional state and there is a very
natural test that achieves both of these
properties okay and the test is well
it's natural but the analysis is pretty
complicated the test is to repeat the
CSH game in sequence many time and to
check if a high enough fraction of the
games is one and this is a test that is
found in record room Grampa's irani and
in the same paper they also use this
test to obtain a verifiable delegated
quantum computation protocol okay so the
key idea to get this just at the very
high level is that the verifier will
alternate rounds in which is testing the
two servers with rounds in which is
asking them to do things that are useful
for the computation and she will do this
in such a way that the two servers can't
distinguish between the two types of
rounds so if they want to behave
optimally in the test sounds they also
have to be
honestly in the things that are useful
for the computation it was just a
high-level idea and so the protocol from
this paper is the first with a classical
very fire and two non communicating
Kruger's the overall complexity in terms
of resources and time used in terms of
with respect to the size of the circuit
being delegated is polynomial
however this polynomial is quite
primitive and so there has been a
sequence of work after this one that has
tried to improve the efficiency of
delegated computation protocols and
often this works these improvements go
through improving the efficiency of the
underlying self tests and so one way
that we can can improve the efficiency
of the underlying self test is for
instance by executing them in parallel
instead of in sequence so this provides
savings and around complexity so there
is been what I mean by by self testing
in parallel is that now you can play say
n copies of the CSH game by asking all
of the questions at once and getting all
of the answers at once and there has
been a series of works recently that has
studied self tests in parallel using
copies of CSH magic square game and
other variants and typically the
robustness that they get is not very
good so it's polynomial in n and epsilon
what I mean by this is that an epsilon
close to optimal strategy implies that
the state used by the the two players
has to be of the order of poly an
epsilon close to any peer pairs so the
problem with this is that the dependence
in n is very bad so as n grows you're
going to be further away further and
further away from the any peer pairs
there is one test that stands out which
is called the poly breeding test or the
quantum linearity test from Natarajan in
Vedic which actually has a robustness
that is independent of the number of EPR
pairs tested
and so one can extend this test to get a
very efficient delegator quantum
computation protocol in this setting in
which the overall complexity is almost
optimal nearly near its order G log G to
delegate a quantum circuit of G gates
okay let me pause for for five seconds
here for questions and here would be the
size of the circuit you know the number
of EPR pairs you would use would
correspond to the size of the circuit is
that right they are related but in
general the size of the circuit I mean
the number of gates right so G so the
number of EPR pairs typically
corresponds more to the number well it
depends on the type of protocol but
typically to the number of qubits that
you're using it depends yeah I guess
also to the number of gates but in
general this bound here that I give on
the overall complexity is in terms of
everything so resources meaning number
of EPR pairs time rounds so the overall
complexity is order G log G so the best
that you can do is obviously just G if
you run the circuit on your own so this
counts everything right I was just
trying to see why the poly and epsilon
won't you'd be unhappy with the poly and
epsilon robustness you know to derive
this result yes n is like besides of the
circuit and the poly n you know oh oh I
see I see I see no I think I think in
general this this comes in the details
of how you actually use the test it I
think it would be hard to convey yes yes
I think this is in the details of the
analysis why we're actually having no
dependence on n is is good
okay so in the very final part of the
talk I just want to tell you about what
I think is one of the recent success
stories of of self testing which is its
connection to foundational questions
about quantum correlation sets and
entanglement so we have seen at the
beginning of the talk we talked a lot
about correlations a correlation is
captured the statistics of a particular
experiment was an example of probability
distributions we talked also about
quantum correlations which are
correlations generated by a quantum
strategy specified by a state and
observables on both sides however I
wasn't very precise in how we should
model this quantum resource but while
it's clear that entanglement plays a
role for instance I didn't specify to
you whether we should allow the hilbert
spaces to be infinite dimensional or we
should restrict them to be finite
dimensional and taking an either for
even further step back I sort of assumed
the tensor product structure but an
equally legitimate starting point would
have been to have a single Hilbert space
H a global Hueber Space Station just
require that the observables on a lesson
website commute ok and each of these
models obviously the latter one is more
general now each of these models defines
a set of all possible attainable
correlations and this set might be
possibly different it's an important
foundational question to determine
whether they're actually different or
they're the same set so here are some of
the more well studied sets of
correlations there's obviously the set C
of classical correlations that you can
attain in a local hidden variable model
and this is strictly contained by Bell's
Theorem in the set of quantum
correlations now I'll use the letter Q
to denote the correlations attainable by
finite dimensional quantum strategies in
the tensor product model now obviously
this is contained in the infinite
dimensional counterpart that I denote
with Q infinity
and we know that this two sets Q and Q
infinity have the same closure where the
closure is just limits of finite or
infinite dimensional quantum correlation
so let me just emphasize that the
elements of these sets are the
correlations themselves not the
strategies so a correlation could be
attained using a very complicated
infinite dimensional strategy but the
correlation is very much a finite object
the size of it depends on the side of
the question sets and the answer set and
finally the closure of this tensor
product model is contained in a most
general model which is all the
correlations attainable in the commuting
operator model with possibly infinite
dimensional strategies and as far as I
know the first person to be interested
in this problem I might be wrong but as
far as I know the first person was
serial son
in particular he was interested in
whether these inclusions are strict or
their equalities and interestingly all
of these inclusions have been resolved
in the last two or three years it turns
out that they are all strict and it
turns out that self testing actually is
at the heart of proving all of this
inclusion so can be used to to prove all
these inclusions and the last missing
piece was the proof that the closure of
the tensor product model is strictly
contained in the commuting operator
model and this follows as a corollary of
the MIT star equals re result which
we'll hear about today and and tomorrow
so I'll and on this positive note and
I'm happy to take questions thank you
so is there any question for forum Oh
Dominic asked if Q commuting is equal to
its closure yes
[Music]
so yeah it's unquestionable so back to
your like the conclusion is less and
less like do for no signaling or like
can you put no signaling anywhere there
this side here
yeah no signaling would include
everything else would be bigger than
everything else and in fact okay they
are strictly strictly bigger yeah I mean
for instance even the ring but yeah for
instance I mean you can already get the
separation if you consider the CH SH
game you can get a probability winning
probability of one using a non signaling
strategy and for quantum you get at most
cost square PI over eight okay I I
wanted to ask a question about the Magic
Square game sure oh they're like you
explained that it is important for
executing the protocol that these
operator strategies are commuting a row
or column and like I understand that
this is like very useful and probably
necessary if you want to run the
protocol but but suppose that someone
gives you a protocol which works so how
do you how do you conclude that it must
commute by row and column like how do
you get these restrictions on the
representations you're saying you are
saying how do I show that a perfect
strategy must have observables that
commute yes I see well so if you if you
write the strategy in terms of right in
general the observable that you add you
measure so you're gonna get us the row
and you're gonna return an answer that
is three bits okay so in general this is
not three different observables there's
just one observable right so you know
there's an observable the resin as an
output 380 bits okay but if
you want to sort of break it down into
three observables one for each bit then
you dual commute if you if you just
write this bigger observables and sort
of marginalize it to get the observable
for each qubit they will commute okay
thanks any other question oh there's a
question on the Q&A so how do you go
from stop testing I stay - stop testing
answer fit well so so this is sort of
relates to the delegated quantum
computation protocol so basically what
okay depending what do you mean so if
you're just happy with sort of
certifying the outcome of a circuit then
we do have protocols for that right like
the ones that I did I mention so you're
guaranteed that the verifier at the end
of the protocol will output the correct
outcome of the combination with high
probability if you actually mean that
you want to certify that really the
provers perform certain gates then
actually you have to be a little bit
more precise like what do you mean by
this because it could be that the
computation is executed maybe on Alice's
side maybe it's executed on Bob's side
but it turns out that for the record on
Grand Vizier any protocol you can
actually certify that the provers are
executing certain quantum circuits so it
is possible to formalize this but I
guess I would have to be I would have to
be more precise on how how you build
this this protocol so how you bootstrap
self tests to arbitrary quantum circuits
[Music]
final question so if not thanks and drag
Andrew again for the very nice talk and
I think we reconvene in 20 minutes
more or less thank you